blm has been nominated
for a nobel peace prize some people are
calling it
the nobel mostly peaceful prize i think
that is
probably true everyone is very upset
because blm obviously was torching the
country for like six months
it doesn't seem very peaceful however
i think this is pretty in keeping with
uh with past winners you've got uh
yasser arafat yasser a uh
terrorist from the middle east right uh
he won
so surely if he won blm can win two
beyond that you've got barack obama one
barack obama started multiple new wars
al gore won the nobel peace prize
and he didn't start any wars as far as i
can tell but
he he has supported a campaign of uh
population suppression he has supported
uh abortion and contraception in the
third world to keep africans from having
too many babies that's that doesn't seem
peaceful
jimmy carter jim carter didn't start any
any new wars
kind of feckless i don't even bring a
bring a ton of peace but fair enough
so sure blm is uh is up for this
a lot of conservatives are saying we
should not nominate blm for this i would
like to go further
and this ties in to cancel culture i
think blm
should be cancelled we should not permit
that organization to operate in the
united states
it is a subversive organization it is
not
only opposed to the structure of the us
government
but it actively tries to overturn those
structures by setting government
buildings on fire
by burning down businesses by torching
city after city after city
it is opposed an idea to the united
states and it is opposed in practice to
the united states
because it attacks law enforcement and
because it attacks
all of these sorts of institutions it is
a subversive organization
it should be prosecuted under the smith
act we were just talking about
mccarthyism
the smith act is an act that was
popular and actually used in the mid
20th century before the supreme court
watered it down
to prosecute communists because you
can't be an open subversive you can't
actively be trying to overturn the
system we can't we can't tolerate
that that amount of
of free expression this sort of
expression that's going to overturn the
entire system
of free expression can't have it like
chesterton said there's a thought that
stops thought
that's the only thought that ought to be
stopped same with antifa we should not
tolerate antifa you might say michael
you're an authoritarian
your views sound so my views are not in
any way authoritarian
we've had these kinds of rules against
sedition and subversive organizations
since the very beginning of the country
my views are no more authoritarian than
thomas jefferson's my views are no more
authoritarian than john lockes who wrote
the letter concerning toleration
in the letter concerning toleration john
locke says atheists under no
circumstances should ever be tolerated
john locke is the father of liberalism
so i just don't want to hear it i don't
want to hear about illiberalism
i don't want to hear about
authoritarianism we need
to have substance this goes all the way
back
to mitch mcconnell's defense of liz
cheney where he says you know she has
convictions
and she leads and she has courage
yeah so does blm blm they lead they have
courage
they have convictions what matters
is what the convictions are
and if the convictions are opposed to
the country itself
those cannot be tolerated if you enjoyed
that break from disinformation
historical revision
and screaming about the end of the world
be sure to hit the subscribe button
so that you never miss another video
[Music]
[Music]